[Music]
all right Joe Biden's border crisis is
now spreading far and wide to every
single corner of this great country of
ours including blue cities which are now
well one Sanctuary cities and states
they're now being overwhelmed with new
arrivals every day every state now is
become a border state from New York to
Denver to Chicago our very own Sarah
Carter spoke to local residents earlier
today take a look at this tell me a
little bit about what's been happening
in your community since the overwhelming
amount of migrants have come in I mean
you know I thought it was a joke when it
was when they said they were going to
all be rushing in and now we're standing
right outside and I'm seeing people
walking in and out down the street and
it's it kind of seems like it's a little
overwhelming we don't know who's here
um honestly we don't need them here
right now I hate to say I'm sure there's
some good people that have come over but
we have to take care of our own we have
homeless veterans walking around with
PTSD and no one takes care of them we'd
have no money for them but we have money
for people that aren't even Americans it
makes absolutely no sense who do you
blame for this
I mean you blame the politicians that's
that's how it starts and I mean the
people that vote for them I don't blame
the Texas governor you know if we're
going to stay here and say oh everyone's
welcome I mean it's a stupid policy the
sanctuary City stuff's a joke uh it's
all woke you know pandering and it needs
to stop right now
all right in fact things were so bad in
Chicago that the city is now spending
get this a whopping 30 million dollars
to move illegals into camps for the
winter and now with Morris our very own
Sarah Carter uh you know I guess that
doesn't meet the 12 billion dollar
estimated cost in New York City or the
Forty thousand dollars per illegal
immigrant in New York uh however when
you have governor hokel and mayor Adams
now you know hokel in particular saying
yeah uh even though we we welcome and
we're so proud of our status as you know
anybody can come from anywhere yeah if
you come into the country illegally just
don't come here uh interesting statement
on her part but this is that bad now for
every state
oh absolutely absolutely Sean and as the
wave of migration continues to grow here
in the city of Chicago they are facing
what they say is a strain on the
resources they've never seen before
remember Chicago's in a budget shortfall
right now of over 50 million dollars and
there's tens of millions of dollars that
are already being spent we were actually
at one of the precincts and I got to
tell you I was overwhelmed I was with
many of the migrants there uh young
children living on the streets in tents
inside the police precincts no police in
sight and then I had an opportunity to
speak with um Alderman Raymond Lopez
about the situation and the crisis here
in Chicago and it's just eye-opening
what he had to say take a listen
what we see here is the fact that
Chicago can't sustain this Chicago can't
answer this crisis because this is the
federal government's failure at the
border brought to our backyard literally
here in the middle of the city of
Chicago in front of a police district as
a scene that's been repeated 22 times
over where we have nearly 1600 people
living in police districts in the
lobbies in tents in the Parkways you
know you can't keep asking in cities
like Chicago whether they are a
sanctuary or not to come up with the
solution for the federal government's
failure Joe Biden Kamala Harris All of
Congress need to get their heads out of
their rear ends and start focusing
what's on what's important and
addressing this issue head on and not
hoping that it magically disappears or
that you could ignore it or wish it away
because that's not working
Sean just this first half of September
alone more than 142
000 people were encountered by federal
law enforcement at the border tens of
thousands have moved their way across
the country and these Shanty towns are
growing Across the Nation as well and I
want you to think about this right now
with that 30 million that they're
allocating towards the tents for the
people as winter comes that won't be
enough these are Arctic cold weather and
what I've been hearing from officials
here in the city of Chicago those tents
are only good to up to 40 degrees above
zero so there's going to be a lot of
people out in the streets there's going
to be a very dangerous situation women
and children as well and they're
terrified that they may see people die
because of this this is how serious it
is well I also know that Chicago has
been sending a lot of the illegal
immigrants to the surrounding suburbs
because in spite of their liberalness
they're not that liberal you know as
long as you move somewhere else we're
all four Sanctuary status but not here
uh Sarah Carter very important report
thank you